enthousiasmant place quasi normal vous
avez planté lors du langage et
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écoutez
scopeo l'observatoire politique je suis
lucas da silva cofondateur de scopeo et
je vous souhaite aujourd'hui la
bienvenue sur ce deuxième épisode de
notre série
l'entrevue politique aujourd'hui nous
sommes très heureux de recevoir monsieur
kevin bossuet mais également deux
professeurs qui viendront nous apporter
leur témoignage
mais avant toute chose je laisse la
parole à maxime fayssac également membre
de scopeo pour qu'ils puissent poser le
décor de ce podcast
et oui merci lucas bonjour à ceux et à
celles qui nous écoutent et surtout
bonjour à vous monsieur bossuet bonjour
vous nous faites l'honneur aujourd'hui
de nous accorder cette entrevue pour
discuter débattre sur un sujet qui vous
tient et nous tient particulièrement à
coeur
suite avec deux tribunes publiées sur
notre site scopeo point org qui
dénonçait un naufrage de l'éducation
nationale veut notamment de l'islamisme
mais aussi d'une certaine idéologie
progressiste
nous allons donc aborder avec vous les
thèmes de cette baisse de niveau
dramatique dans nos écoles ainsi que
celle de l' attaque qui est fait
aujourd'hui contre le modèle de
l'enseignement républicain mais avant de
démarrer cette entrevue que monsieur
bruce fait je vous laisse bien sûr vous
présenter écoutez moi je suis professeur
d'histoire-géographie donc je pensais
depuis 2013 donc ça fait maintenant
septembre que plus de 7 ans j'enseigne
en collège c'est un choix parce que je
trouve que défendre les valeurs de la
république
on est beaucoup plus optimale à faire
cela en collège parce qu'au lycée il est
peut-être un peu trop tard et j'enseigne
en seine saint denis seine saint denis
département que j'ai également choisi
donc je ne suis pas comme beaucoup de
mes collègues dans un département qui
motive puisque j'ai choisi justement ce
département alors après les gens me
connaissent souvent avec ma présence
médiatique
c'est vrai que je suis assez présent
aussi bien dans la presse web la presse
écrite valeur actuelle j'ai écrit
quelques articles pour marianne
mais également pour d'autres journaux
également ma présence à la radio je suis
un régulier de sud radio qui plus
récemment ma présence à la télévision à
travers russie a tout des france ou
encore à travers ses news
donc voilà alors très bien c'est un
honneur pour nous de vous avoir parmi
nous on va commencer tout de suite dans
le vif du sujet on va commencer avec la
question de la baisse du niveau général
des élèves au sein de l'éducation
nationale
récemment rené chiche également
professeur à sortir un livre qui
s'appelle la désinscription nationale
donc je m'appuie en partie sur ce livre
pour parler de ce naufrage est
réellement du niveau des élèves
est ce que vous vous partagez avec
monsieur chiche
ce constat d'une des instructions
nationale
quand je n'aime pas le terme d
instruction nationale par contre ce que
je peux vous dire
en effet il ya une baisse de niveau qui
et grandiloquent d'ailleurs on me
demande souvent en tant que professeur
d'histoire est ce que le niveau baisse
j'ai l'habitude de répondre non le
niveau de baisse pas du tout il n'ya
juste plus de niveau du tout il est
évident que depuis ces dernières années
il ya une baisse du niveau scolaire que
cela soit en français que cela soit en
mathématiques ou que cela soit de
manière plus générale en sciences
humaines et sociales et plus
particulièrement une histoire géographie
puisqu'au j'enseigne cette discipline et
c'est quelque chose qui est de plus en
plus important il suffit d'ailleurs
d'interroger mes collègues du supérieur
qui me disent quand je n'y vois toujours
mais qu'est ce que vous faites dans
l'enseignement secondaire c'est quelque
chose qui est dramatique puisque nous on
récupère des étudiants qui ne savent
même plus écrire une phrase en bon
français ou qui ont des gros problèmes
de des campagnes de méthodes des gros
problèmes de compréhension de texte et
c'est donc là c'est évident qu'il ya une
baisse de niveau alors après j'aimerais
aussi un petit peu pour des risques que
je raconte c'est vrai qu'à une baisse de
niveau général mais cette baisse de vos
concerne surtout les établissements les
moins favorisées notamment les
établissements de banlieue il suffit de
prendre le classement pisa pour se
rendre compte qu'il ya un très grand fou
c'est entre les collèges les lycées de
centre-ville et les collèges et les
lycées de banlieue ça s'explique de
différentes manières il est évident que
dans les lycées les collèges de banlieue
on a affaire à des catégories socio
professionnelles qui sont relativement
bas c'est donc ce qui fait que les
enfants qui sont dans ces quartiers ont
moins bed à la maison que que d'autres
élèves et ça s'explique aussi peu
forcément ils sont dans un environnement
social où il ya moins d'interactions
culturelle intellectuelle
ça se voit beaucoup et c'est vrai que
dans ces zones là aussi vous avez
souvent
un enseignement à l'école primaire qui
n'est pas toujours efficient avec 1 tour
9 heures des enseignants avec des
enseignants du primaire qui sont souvent
des contractuels et qui n'ont pas été
formés au métier ou tout simplement qui
font ça pour gagner leur vie
on se retrouve avec des hells vous
voulez qui pendant plusieurs mois n'ont
pas eu droit à l'enseignement auquel il
aurait eu droit
et puis il ya une dernière aussi
explication qui que mais très bien en
avant le classement le l'étude pisa
c'est tout simplement le taux d'un
disciple il est évident que quand vous
êtes dans les banlieues françaises vous
avez un tout d'un discipline qui est
très très important ou sur une heure de
cours le professeur soit n'arrive pas du
tout à fait recours le professeur est
obligé de consacrer 20 25 minutes de son
cours à faire taire les élèves ou à
régler les problèmes disciplinaires ou
tous les problèmes sociaux qui lie à
autour de cela quand vous allez au
contraire dans des établissements de
centre ville on a c'est vrai - des
problèmes de discipline et c'est vrai
qu'on a peut-être beaucoup plus de cours
qui font un véritablement 55 minutes ou
une heure donc moi je pense que voilà
c'est cette baisse de niveau n général
des concentrés elle se concentre surtout
sur certains pans du territoire national
encore merci monsieur notionnels pour
cette première réponse qui permet
d'aborder de nombreux éléments qu'on
voudrait a évoqué sur ce thème l'art de
l'éducation nationale mais vous avez
abordé cette baisse du niveau de
français généralement que vous pointez
principalement dans les banlieues
malheureusement cette baisse du niveau
de l'orthographe et du niveau de
français en général je pense qu'elle est
très général au niveau au niveau du pays
comment vous expliquer cette baisse
inquiétante du niveau de la maîtrise du
français
comment y remédier et ça me permet
également de vous poser la question de
la réforme de l'orthographe est ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne solution ou au
contraire un nivellement vers le bas
alors c'est sûr qu'il ya une baisse du
niveau de manière beaucoup plus générale
tout simplement parce que il y a
l'importance accordée à la langue
française dans notre société qui est
moins gras aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on
parle de plus en plus anglais il est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on se soucie peu
finalement
du fait que l'on maîtrise ou non un bon
français et c'est vrai peut-être que
notre culture nationale qui est d'abord
basé sur la langue tellement dépressif
finalement on trouve que parler à un bon
français n'est plus véritablement très
important alors après il est vrai qu'il
ya aussi un problème de méthodologie
pendant il ya eu si vous avez une
révolution pédagogique au sein de
l'éducation nationale qui a surtout eu
lieu autour de mai 68 ans dans les
années soixante dix où on a complètement
revu la manière d'enseigner et même la
philosophie de l'enseignement avant il y
avait un maître qui était dans la classe
qui étaient là notamment pour
transmettre des savoirs pour faire en
sorte que les élèves savent lire écrire
et compter et c'est vrai qu'avec cette
révolution soixante huitarde au sein de
l'éducation nationale
on a un peu oublié ces objectifs pu tout
d'abord par exemple on sait de moins en
moins de dicter voilà on fait de moins
en moins de 10 t on demande de plus en
plus aux professeurs de danse et n'y ait
de moins en moins à l'orthographe ou de
moins en moins la grammaire et surtout
on demande aux enseignants que les
élèves soient acteurs de leur propre
savoir c'est à dire qu'ils construisent
eux-mêmes leur propre savoir ce qui
revient globalement à les laisser seuls
face à leurs propres difficultés non ça
c'est quelque chose qui est évidemment
dramatique
et puis je crois de manière plus
générale c'est qu'il y a eu cette
volonté finalement idéologique de deepa
au sein de l'éducation nationale c'est
quelque chose qui est plus général de
saper les fondements de la langue
française de s'en prendre à notre langue
française se s'en prendre à la langue
française finalement c'est s'en prendre
à notre culture
et finalement dire que la langue
française ne l'a plus véritablement de
rennes là on peut construire ses propres
règles par rapport à cette dernière et
on peut prendre ses distances par
rapport à cette dernière il ya un
exemple qui est quand même fondamental
qui est apparu au cours de ces dernières
années c'est la fameuse écriture
inclusive qui commence à être de plus en
plus importante dans nos manuels
scolaires qui fait que finalement on
torpille la langue française sur l'autel
de l'idéologie est ce qu'il ya de plus
dramatique c'est que beaucoup
d'enseignants qui sont des idéologues
patentés des idéologues de gauche
n'hésite pas maintenant de plus en plus
à écrire en écriture inclusive au sein
de l'établissement scolaire mêmes
commencent progressivement à enseigner
une forme d'écriture inclusive on s'est
peut-être encore un phénomène marginal
mais malheureusement ça existait
d'ailleurs il suffit de voir le niveau
des jeunes collègues qui arrivent pour
se rendre compte que finalement ils sont
aussi le fruit de ces nouvelles méthodes
qui sont finalement si le fruit de cette
éducation nationale il y a beaucoup de
collègues qui ne maîtrisent pas
forcément la langue française il suffit
de regarder sur les bulletins scolaires
pour compter le nombre de fautes qu'il y
a au niveau des appréciations donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose de plus
générale de ces complètement idéologique
que ça a été plus
et puis de manière aussi plus grande on
est quand même dans une société on
accorde de moins en moins d'importance
au collectif ce qui nous relie au
collectif et il ya une chose qui nous
relie au collectif c'est bien là mais la
maîtrise d'une même langue et on ne peut
plus on n'est plus dans une société
individualiste où finalement chacun
possède sa propre langue on mélange
l'anglais on mélange le français et
maintenant par sms voire le langage sms
ça devient n'importe quoi par voilà on
est dans une forme de destruction de
notre culture nationale dont l'école est
le reflet justement c'est intéressant
parce que donc ça fait on peut dire que
vous êtes relativement un jeune
professeur donc il
si longtemps que ça que vous avez
assisté à la formation justement et vous
parliez de ses jeunes collègues qui
arrivent et qui soit sont porteurs d'une
certaine idéologie que ce soit vis-à-vis
de l'écriture inclusive ou autre chose
est-ce que vous dans votre souvenir ou
même peut-être vous êtes au courant de
l'évolution des choses il ya quelque
chose qui manque à la formation des
profs ou est ce que justement il ya des
choses en trop peut-être
vis-à-vis d'une formation qui est
idéologique je pense qu'il ya une chose
qui manque c'est le salaire alors
pourquoi je vous dis ça vous n'allez pas
comprendre ce que je vous dis mais je
pense que c'est déterminant parce
qu'aujourd'hui les professeurs sont sous
payés et quand vous sont payés les
jambes et finalement les meilleurs
étudiants ne vont plus dans
l'enseignement
ils préfèrent aller vers d'autres
contrées donc finalement on se retrouve
avec un recrutement qui est nivelé par
le bas et avec des collègues qui arrive
qui ont choisi l'enseignement foot de
mieux ou tout simplement qui ont choisi
l'enseignement parce que ça leur
permettait d'avoir un peu de temps libre
et ça leur permettait par exemple de
travailler tout en s'occupant de leurs
enfants
voilà je crois que c'est déjà aussi
c'est fondamental c'est parce que
forcément les meilleurs forcément ça se
voit au niveau de la qualité de
l'enseignement ensuite au niveau de la
formation des enseignants
écoutez moi moi moi c'est un peu
particulier parce que moi j'ai pas connu
la réforme de la réforme du recrutement
des professeurs puisque maintenant les
enseignants doivent absolument valider
un master sciences de l'éducation ce
qu'on appelle les master mef dans
lesquels on n'apprend pas grand chose
dans lesquelles il ya beaucoup de ventes
et finalement on ne prépare pas les
enseignants au terrain moi au contraire
j'ai un master 2 d'histoire joue c'est
un master de sciences politiques donc
j'ai fait de la recherche à travers
différents mémoires moi c'est cela qui
m'a permis finalement d'améliorer ma
connaissance disciplinaire d'avoir
peut-être une autre connaissance de ma
discipline et de pouvoir transmettre
convenablement les savoir que j'ai à
transmettre parce qu'il est évident
qu'un
mon professeur c'est d'abord celui qui
maîtrise parfaitement son savoir
disciplinaire quand en 6e vous avez par
exemple un chapitre sur l'orient ancien
au troisième millénaire à faire passer
si vous n'avez aucune connaissance de
l'orient ancien à parce que je lisais
dans les manuels scolaires vous aurez
beau avoir les meilleures méthodes
pédagogiques vous n'arriverez pas à
faire passer des bonnes connaissances
puisque vous ne maîtrisez pas
parfaitement ce que vous demandez à vos
élèves de maîtriser donc ça pose des
questions et puis je reviens cette
révolution soixante huitards qui était
complètement désastreuse qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui l'enseignant n'est plus
seulement là pour transmettre des
connaissances mais l'enseignant est
aussi là pour transmettre des
connaissances des compétences c'est à
dire aujourd'hui
en gros je caricature c'est complètement
caricaturale que ce que je vais vous
dire mais c'est pour vous faire
comprendre on se fiche complètement si
les élèves mais connaissent et dan les
dates du règne de louis xiv qui est
important c'est de valider la compétence
est ce que je cherche je sais chercher
des dates de règne de louis xiv par
exemple sur internet donc finalement on
crée des enfants qui sont qui dont le
but est qu'ils soient employables sur le
marché du travail
on écrit on ne crée plus des enfants
dont voudrait qu'ils aient un esprit
critique aiguisé et qu'ils deviennent
des citoyens responsables des citoyens
cultivés et des citoyens aptes à avoir
un esprit critique important donc je
pense que c'est une combinaison de tout
cela et puis pour revenir à votre
question départ sur l'idéologie des
enseignants l'éducation nationale
évidemment c'est c'est encore là où on a
le plus de gens qui ont une idéologie
gauchiste le plus de gens qui
l'idéologie socialiste selon l'idéologie
communiste etc c'est un fort si vous
voulez moi j'ai l'habitude de dire que
le mur de berlin est tombé partout sauf
dans l'éducation nationale c'est quelque
chose qui est dramatique parce que ça a
des conséquences sur la manière dont on
voit l'enseignement je veux dire qu'il
ya cette volonté si vous voulez
une salle de classe toujours abandonné
les meilleurs élèves en se disant
finalement le mérite c'est pas forcément
une valeur qui est bien et on va se
concentrer plutôt sur les élèves qui
sont les plus en difficulté ce qui est
tout à fait louable et c'est aussi ça
notre métier mais le problème c'est
qu'en faisant ça on abandonne quand même
on abandonne carrément les meilleurs
élèves qu'on pourrait par exemple sortir
des milieux ruraux on pourrait par
exemple sortir des banlieues pour en
faire pour pour essayer de renouer avec
cette ascension sociale qui est qui et
quand même à la base de nos valeurs
républicaines
justement comment analyser dans cette
perspective là la réforme du bac est ce
que pour vous c'est une pseudo solution
est ce que c'est peut-être une solution
il ya des choses qui sont bonnes à
prendre dedans parce que on voit qu'on
demande aux élèves un grand oral
dorénavant ça paraît de plus en plus
techniques ce qui ne sorte de paradoxe
parce que le niveau semble baisser de
manière générale vous qu'est-ce que
comment vous analysez la réforme gbagbo
dans cette perspective il a écouté et
philosophiquement je pense que la
réforme du baccalauréat est une bonne
réforme
le problème c'est que c'est une bonne
à partir du moment où les élèves à riom
arrivent en seconde en maîtrisant les
fondamentaux en maîtrisant l'écriture en
maîtrisant la lecture en maîtrisant le
socle de connaissances et des
compétences
or ce n'est malheureusement pas le cas
et c'est ça qui est un petit peu
désastreux si vous voulez dans cette
réforme parce que l'idée que finalement
les lèvres à construire son propre
parcours qu'arriver en classe de seconde
maintenant il sait écrire il sait lire
une ses comptes et il a les bases en
histoire et en géographie et que
maintenant c'est à lui de construire ce
qui le veut devenir et les enseignements
les enseignements qu'il veut choisir je
pense que c'est plutôt une bonne chose
mais on a ciblé une réforme qui
abandonne peut-être ceux qui ne
maîtrisent pas tout à fait les savoirs
fondamentaux mais en même temps j'ai
envie de dire si vous arrivez en seconde
et que vous ne maîtrisez pas les savoirs
fondamentaux
je pense que de toute manière s'il est
trop tard et ça va être un petit peu
compliqué alors après les fêtes et
revers de cette réforme aussi c'est la
différence territoriales parce qu'il est
évident que ces options c'est parce que
maintenant ça fonctionne par option il
ya beaucoup plus d'options dans les
lycées de centre ville que dans les
lycées ruraux
là où il ya beaucoup moins d'élèves vrai
là on peut beaucoup moins ouvrir
d'options c'est vrai peut-être que ça
aggrave les différences territoriales et
c'est un petit peu dommage mais de
manière plus générale moi je trouve que
au lycée c'est bien aussi d'avoir un peu
plus de souplesse ou lycées c'est bien
aussi que les élèves puissent choisir
leur enseignement
au lycée je trouve aussi bien que les
élèves puissent construire leurs propres
parcours
donc voilà je pense que c'est plutôt une
bonne chose par contre il faut aussi
intensifier le travail autour de
l'orientation
parce qu'il ya un fossé très important
dans notre dans notre société
entre ceux qui savent très bien où
s'orienter et ceux qui ne savent pas où
s'orienter entre ceux qui savent dans
quel établissement du supérieur
il faut aller et entre ceux qui ne
savent pas dans quel établissement du
supérieur
il faut aller et c'est vrai peut-être
quel petit peut-être une petite lacune
là dessus mais même si jean-michel
blanquer a renforcé cela ou lycées mais
je pense qu'il faut faire encore un peu
plus d'ailleurs de manière plus générale
qui réussit aujourd'hui dans le système
scolaire français se sont évidemment pas
les six sont évidemment pas les six oui
les filles d'employés ce sont les tice
où les filles d'enseignants tout
simplement parce que les enseignants
connaissent très bien le système
scolaire français
et ce sont les fils de la bonne
bourgeoisie parce que ne connaissent
également très bien notre système
scolaire d'accord merci merci monsieur
bossuet pour ses réponses on a eu des
questions très générales sur la réforme
du bac sur sur la chute du niveau
scolaire en france on va se pencher un
peu plus sur l'autorité et la figure du
professeur parce que vous semblez
partager ce constat selon lequel la
figure de l'enseignant aurait perdu en
autorité au fil du temps il aura perdu
un peu la maîtrise sur sa classe et donc
si vous partagez ce constat comment vous
pouvez imaginer une réhabilitation de la
figure du professeur dans sa classe
déjà c'est la question du salaire à
partir du moment où on soupire ah
évidemment les professeurs n'est
professeur n'auront pas la place qu'ils
doivent avoir au sein de la société ça
c'est quelque chose qui est fondamental
qu'en demandé à des élèves s'il veut
devenir prof qui vont vous racontez nous
on ne veut pas devenir prendre tout
simplement parce que vous gagnez gagner
rien enfin voila c'est complètement sous
payé un débutant dans l'enseignement
secondaire game 1700 euros par mois
après un bac +5 et après l'obtention
d'un concours dans à l'école primaire je
crois que c'est moi je crois que c'est
autour on débute autour de 1300 à 1400
euros donc c'est quelque chose qui n'est
pas acceptable et la baisse de
l'autorité du professeur commence déjà
par là ensuite il y a philosophie si
vous voulez qui n'est encore une fois de
cette révolution soixante huitarde on a
voulu casser l'autorité du maître cas
c'est l'autorité du professeur on a 1000
élèves au même niveau que le professeur
ce qui est complètement stupide ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui finalement
concrètement quand un élève se comporte
mal dans dans la plupart des cas on
demande maintenant aux professeurs de
s'excuser puisque c'est lui qui aurait
mal géré la classe où c'est lui qui
n'auraient pas eu le bon comportement
vis-à-vis de l'élève qui aurait dérapé
ce qui est inadmissible ce qui est
incompréhensible dans une société si
vous voulez civilisé en outre il ya
aussi le rôle de l'éducation parentale
je veux dire aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de parents qui sont démissionnaires qui
n'apprennent plus à leurs enfants le
respect de l'autorité qui qui qui
tissent des enfants qui sont sans arrêt
choyés c'est ce que c'est ce que mettant
en avant barbara ne servent notre
professeur de l'éducation nationale qui
n'est pas sur ces news elle qui est sur
lci donc voilà qu'on se partage
finalement l'échelle et qui à travers
son ouvrage génération j'ai droit à a
mis en avant au combien le fait de
toujours dire ni
aux désirs des enfants faisait en sorte
qu'ils n'acceptaient plus les crues
stration et qui ne supportait plus le
fait si vous voulez qu'on puisse leur
donner des consignes ou qu'on puisse
leur donner des ordres je crois qu'à un
moment donné il faut aussi agir sur le
cercle parental parce que ce n'est pas
normal que des gamins arrivent en
n'ayant pas suivi une éducation tel
qu'il aurait dû subir et surtout ou
alors par exemple des enfants qui ne
vont même pas à l'école où il ya un
absentéisme de plus en plus important il
ya julien aubert je connais plutôt bien
qu'ils aient un député les républicains
qui a proposé récemment par exemple de
supprimer les allocations familiales aux
parents démissionnaires ou parents qui
ne s'occupent pas de leurs enfants moi
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
chose d'ailleurs jean-michel blanquer
retard pris à un moment donné mais
forcément il a très vite abandonné la
chose face une majorité qui est quand
même beaucoup plus à gauche que à droite
justement plus grand rayonnement
souvient récemment dans le nord de la
france avaient eu tout un débat c'est
plus dans quelle ville cet événement ne
s'était pas arras mais je veux pas dire
de bêtises où il y avait un maire local
qui avait dit qu'il y avait prévu
d'enlever les allocations aux familles
aux parents dont les enfants étaient
considérés comme les enfants mineurs
déjà des délinquants et savez-vous et où
tu ne savait créer toute une levée de
boucliers exactement ça c'est un
discours qu'on entend good il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent
l'instruction doit être faite à l'école
mais l'éducation doit être fait à la
maison et ça me permet de rebondir sur
une autre piste en sait quelque chose
c'est une mesure vous parlez des mesures
que de cette mesure là une autre mesure
que beaucoup de personnes notamment
parmi les gens qui font constat d'un
problème dans l'éducation nationale
parle c'est la mesure de l'uniforme
parce que des gens qui disent que ce
serait une manière à la fois de rétablir
l'autorité et l'égalitarisme à l'école
mais ça serait aussi un moyen pour
défendre la laïcité donc vous sur cette
question l'uniforme comment comment vous
positionnez vous écoutez je suis pour le
port de l'uniforme je mets mes crimes et
le tribune pour valeurs actuelles en
disant qu'il fallait en effet le retour
de l'uniforme ou du moins ce serait une
bonne chose mais encore une fois vous
avez beau avoir toutes les bonnes idées
du monde quand vous avez un corps
professoral qu'imagine majoritairement à
gauche majoritairement à l'extrême
gauche on sait très bien que de toute
façon c'est profane n'acquitteront pas
ce qu'on leur dit d'appliquer ces ça en
fait qui est catastrophique regardez il
ya encore quelques mois on a obligé les
établissements à mettre dans les salles
de classe un drapeau français ou à
mettre la marseillaise mais en fait cela
c'est présent nulle part
c'est complètement tombé à l'eau et je
pense que ça n'a pas été appliquée tout
simplement de manière idéologique et
même jean michel blanquer pourquoi il a
autant de mal à la tête de l'éducation
nationale alors que c'est un homme
brillant alors que c'est un homme de
bonne volonté alors que c'est un homme
qui a des bonnes idées pour l'éducation
nationale tout simplement parce qu'il
doit faire avec une masse de professeurs
qui de toute façon quoi qu'il dise le
combat le combattre a toujours
politiquement donc c'est très compliqué
si vous voulez d'imposer des réformes à
des gens qui n'en veulent pas c'est pour
ça que moi le problème majeur de
l'éducation nationale c'est un problème
et déontologiques
il faut revoir le recrutement augmenter
les salaires pour essayer d'aller
recruter des gens qui ne sont pas dans
une idéologie du nivellement par le bas
de l'égalitarisme forcené qui ne
confondent pas enseignement et
militantisme politique mais qui sont là
tout simplement avec un discours
républicain avec la véritable envie de
faire repartir
l'ascenseur social mal tout est dans ce
recrutement là et c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui pose problème d'accord
d'accord il est est ce que justement sur
ce modèle républicain
il ya selon vous une urgence une
nécessité de réaffirmer la laïcité au
sein de nos écoles et si oui par quels
moyens
vous êtes vous-même enseignants et ce
sera également l'occasion pour vous nous
de nous révéler si vous allez constater
vous même des atteintes à la laïcité ou
des comportements préoccupant dans les
écoles que ce soit venant d'élèves de
parents ou des professeurs les atteintes
à la laïcité sont des atteintes qu'ils
sont permanentes à partir du moment
vous êtes à certains endroits du
territoire vous avez en face de vous des
élèves qui sont majoritairement
musulmans qu forcément il va y avoir si
vous voulez la rencontre entre une
culture arabo-musulmane et la rencontre
entre une culture républicaine et
parfois ça ne fait pas forcément bon
ménage et en plus ces enfants là ne sont
absolument pas responsables ils ont
grandi dans un environnement avec telle
ou telle valeur une fréquente l
association de quartier on leur apprend
à une telle valeur puis ils se
retrouvent jour au lendemain si vous
voulez dans nos salles de classe on leur
dit parfois le contraire de ce que leur
de ce que leur ont dit leurs parents
puisque lors on dit ce que leur a dit
leur entraîneur de saut donc forcément
c'est assez compliqué et donc si vous
voulez ce qu'il faut dire aujourd'hui
est ce qui est important de dire c'est
que l'islam politique
aujourd'hui à pénétrer l'école de la
république et cela fait des années qu'on
alerte l'a26 déjà en 2002 vous avez un
ouvrage qui est sorti les territoires
perdus de la république 1 dirigée par
georges bensoussan qui avait déjà montré
à quel point cette culture arabo
musulmane était compliqué était
compliqué ah si vous voulez aménager
quand on devait faire en sorte que de
lutter contre l'homophobie de lutter
contre l'antisémitisme ou de lutter
contre le sexisme et même à l'époque on
mettait en avant le fait que les
professeurs étaient très gauchisé
d'ailleurs il ya barbara le voir
participer à cet ouvrage quand elle
était dans son lycée elle a été
complètement blacklisté par l'ensemble
de ses collègues parce que on la juge
est beaucoup trop à droite où elle
mettait le doigt où ça faisait mal et
quand elle sortait du lycée il y avait
les grands frères qui l'utilisaient qui
lui faisaient le signe de l'égorgement
voyez on était en 2002 on était au tout
début de cette prise de conscience de
cette pénétration de l'islam politique
au sein de l'école et surtout il ya eu
en 2004 le rapport obin donc jean pierre
robin c'était un haut-fonctionnaire
éducation nationale qui a sorti un
rapport un rapport en 2004 vous alerter
sur la montée de l'islam politique au
sein de la colle de l'école de la
république déjà à l'époque il parlait de
savoir ne pouvait plus transmettre il
mettait même en avant le terme de
théologie nation de l'enseignement en
disant que certains professeurs étaient
obligés si vous voulez de deux hommes
ont été obligés de sortir le corps ans
de justifier les connaissances qu'il
transmettait par rapport au coran et
quand vous lisez ce rapport on parle
même une contre-société par rapport à
une société moderne
et puis surtout il ya nous intéressant
que vous parliez du rapport obin parce
que le rapport obin petite pub pense que
mes os c'était un peu le centre de
l'article que j'ai rédigée sur la
question de la laïcité à l'éducation
nationale dans l'éducation nationale
parce que après ce rapport obin en effet
ce haut fonctionnaire qui était
inspecteur de l'éducation nationale
il ya eu un livre un livre oui qui est
sorti cette année comment on a laissé
l'islamisme pénétrer comme mais
justement ça me permet de sa me
permettre de rebondir vous parlez de
barbares lefebre qui n'était pas a
soutenu que ce soit par ses professeurs
par les parents d'élèves et qui se
sentait seul ce sentiment de solitude de
ce qu'on a compris
c'était un peu la position dans laquelle
était monsieur pâtit monsieur pâtit dans
son court visiblement il était déjà été
la cible d'attaqués des parents d'élèves
et pourtant personne ne semblait
vraiment le souvenir c'est encore arrivé
il ya quelques jours encore une fois des
parents d'élèves auprès d'un enseignant
qui avait fait un coup sur la lega lyon
entre aurait qui s'est plaint jeu dans
une cave voulu démissionner et je me
permets juste un petit fact checking
parlera ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'était pas le maire d'arras qui avoue
lui qui a supprimé les allocations c'est
le maire de valence ont pas du tout en
or de la france dans le sud mais bon
est-ce que pour revenir à la question
est ce que vous vous pensez qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens de 2 entre guillemets
de samuel pâtit aujourd'hui qui sont
dans cette situation d'être lâchés par
leur hiérarchie par leurs collègues est
seul face aux attaques des parents
d'élèves doués ou des grands frères eng
dit
après je n'aime pas incriminer
l'éducation nationale parce que
l'éducation nationale fait avec la
société qu'elle à effet avec les élèves
qui a enfin c'est compliqué aussi pour
l'institution sur certaines parties du
territoire d'affirmer les valeurs
républicaines
si vous voulez un enseignant soit le
problème c'est qu'il est seul face à sa
classe il est très peu inspecté il a
inspecté tous les trois quatre cinq six
ans parfois ça fait dix ans qu'il n'a
jamais inspecté même si cela change un
peu avec la mise en place des rendez
vous de carrière mais finalement
l'enseignant et est seul face à sa
classe voilà c'est ce qu'il veut devant
sa classe et c'est vrai que les
problèmes qu'il peut rencontrer souvent
il est garde pour lui où souvent il est
tellement dans une atmosphère finalement
c'est quelque chose de normal qui ne les
relève même plus
alors après si on quitte la salle de
classe et quand l'enseignant fait
remonter les problèmes c'est vrai qu'il
ya une forme de philosophie de pas de
vagues vers l'institution n'a pas
forcément envie de faire de vague n'a
pas forcément envie de créer des
problèmes parce que je pense que
l'institution a aussi peur que le
problème dans les banlieues lui saute à
la figure donc c'est vrai qu'on a plutôt
tendance finalement mais vous comprenez
vous insulter mais c'est un enfant
allait n'allait pas porter plainte
allez on va arranger ça autrement certes
cet élève à lui à propos un peu
particulier on va lui donner une petite
punition mais ça sert à ça sert à rien
d'aller plus loin je dire on est aussi
dans cette forme de philosophie parce
que j'ai l'impression que l'éducation
nationale est aussi dépassé par toutes
ces problématiques sociétales c'est très
compliqué pour elle de d contre cela
voilà je pense que voilà on peut pas
parler de soutien de la hiérarchie
ils ont qu'on est dans ses notes dans
une institution on essaye de faire en
sorte que ça se passe bien même si
toujours ça se passe pas trop bien
très bien monsieur bossuet après avoir
abordé ces questions de laïcité ça me
permet de rebondir justement sur
l'enseignement de l'histoire parce que
vous êtes vous-même professeur
d'histoire-géo je le rappelle est ce que
pour vous il faut privilégier
l'enseignement du roman national ou un
enseignement qui se rapproche plus de la
science historique est également une
deuxième question qui sous tend ce m6
est ce que pour vous les programmes sont
trop lourds pour être correctement
renseigné et ça pose cette question de
la duperie ville et du privilège de la
quantité sur la qualité alors la
première question est ce qu'il faut
enseigner un roman national
un roman national moi je n'aime pas le
terme parce que bon c'est un terme qui
fait référence à l'enseignement
d'airness la vie sain les manières bon
lancer et à l'histoire à la fin du 19e
siècle au début du 20e siècle au moment
où finalement on devait préparer les
petits français à la guerre et on devait
recréer chez eux un sentiment
patriotique très important alors après
si vous voulez est-ce qu'il faut renouer
avec un récit national je préfère se
taire moi je pense que oui
le problème si vous voulez
l'enseignement de l'histoire aujourd'hui
c'est que finalement elle oscille entre
repentance et dénigrement et surtout
elle ne permet plus de créer un
sentiment patriotique qui crée ce cette
fierté ou cet amour d'être français et
c'est ce qui pose en effet problème par
exemple quand vous voyez le programme de
4e en histoire géographie
on commence par la colonisation et on
voit la colonisation à travers quoi à
travers nos récits d'un esclave et
évidemment on insiste beaucoup sur les
méfaits de l esclavage et ça il faut le
faire parce que l'esclavagé quelque
chose dit c'était quelque chose
d'horrible
on insiste aussi beaucoup sur les
méfaits de la connu de la colonisation
sans jamais insister sur les sur les
conséquences aussi positive en termes de
d'apport civilisationnel en termes
d'apport l'infrastructure et ça c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu dommage âme
de même par exemple en 4e lorsqu'on
évoque le 19e siècle en fait le
programme c'est quoi c'est aborder la
question politique
au 19e siècle
vers 9h démocratique et souvent on
n'étudie même plus qui était napoléon
1er qui était napoléon iii c'est à dire
des grands héros national dans lesquels
les élèves pourraient se reconnaître en
effet ça c'est complètement dramatique
moi je pense qu'il faut renouveler si
vous voulez avec une forme de
patriotisme au sein de l'école de la
république parce que moi ce qui me
choque c'est que tous ces terroristes
qui sont nés sur notre territoire
national les mohamed merah les coulibaly
tous ces gens là en fait ont passé toute
leur scolarité sur les bancs de la de
l'école de l'armée qui guident et puis
finalement au bout de plusieurs années
d'enseignement ils ont commis un
attentat contre le pays qui les a vu
naître contre le pays qui les a vu
grandir donc moi je me dis on a
forcément raté quelque chose
ensuite pour répondre au deuxième partie
de votre question non je ne pense pas
que les
les programmes sont trop chargées au
contraire si vous voulez on a
complètement vidé les programmes
scolaires de leur substance je vais
prendre un exemple encore par exemple la
classe de 4e
on est obligé d'enseignés d'enseigner la
révolution française de 1789 à 1815 en
cinq ou six heures contrôle compris donc
comment voulez vous enseigner
correctement la révolution française
en seulement une semaine et demie en
seulement six heures c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas possible
et finalement j'ai l'impression que les
élèves ressortent de cet enseignement en
ne sachant pas trop ce qu'ils ont appris
et puis surtout il faut renouer avec la
chronologie c'est quelque chose qui est
important quand vous abordez en
cinquième le moyen-âge il ya plus de
chronologie dit oh on n'étudie pas une
des grands rois de france mais on y tue
10 par exemple la place des paysans dans
la société c'est aux dalles la place de
l'église etc etc et les élèves étudient
des grands thèmes sans avoir aucune
notion chronologique c'est complètement
dévastateur et ça c'est le fruit de la
réforme socialiste de madame najat
vallaud belkacem qui a complètement
cassé le collège sur l'autel de sa
petite
idéologie socialisante alors jean-michel
blanc terre a essayé de limiter les
dégâts notamment au lycée puisque au
lycée le lycée souffrait aussi de ce
manque de chronologie dans les
programmes d'histoire il a il a un peu
retrouvé fait en sorte que les
programmes renoue avec la chronologie au
lycée mais au collège il faut absolument
changer ses programmes pour essayer de
les voir autrement parce que c'est
compliqué si vous voulez de faire
apprendre l'histoire à des enfants s'ils
n'ont aucune notion chronologique
donc c'est intéressant parce qu on a pu
parler de lycéens
on a pu parler de collégiens mais je
pense que maintenant ça serait vraiment
intéressant de voir comment ça se passe
au tout début encore à l'école primaire
et donc c'est pour ça que nous avons
avec nous aujourd'hui deux professeurs
du primaire
je vais tout d'abord appelée camille qui
est institutrice en maternelle et qu'a
voulu venir avec nous dans cette
entrevue pour donner un témoignage de
terrain et nous expliquer ce que ce
qu'elle a vu donc amis est ce que est ce
que tu nous entends
oui je vous entends alors du coup donc
moi j'ai obtenu mon concours de
professeurs des écoles dont tu te sers
que l'année passée et j'ai été à la
suite de sa affecté donc à mi temps dans
une école primaire donc en l'occurrence
pas en classe de maternelle et donc je
suis à la fois enseignante donc dans sa
classe de maternelle deux jours par
semaine et à la fois en formation
puisque même après l'obtention du
concours on nous avons encore une
formation encore plus ou moins continue
pour terminer finalement voilà
d'apprendre un petit peu le métier en
vue d'obtenir ensuite un poste à plein
temps à la rentrée prochaine et donc je
vais rebondir sur ce que vous avez pu
dire monsieur le bossu et concernant la
formation
tout d'abord moi j'ai voulu faire ce
métier par amour du savoir par amour de
la transmission parce que j'avais des
souvenirs plus ou moins voilà des
représentations de l'école où l'enfant
apprend l'enfant écoute écoute
l'enseignant n'a goût du savoir on
découvre des choses tous les jours et
c'est donc je vais percer dans cette
idée là deux mois pour devenir
enseignante et transnet or une fois que
nous arrivons en formation on nous
annonce que on nous annonce on s'en
doute plus ou moins par diverses tâches
on peut effectuer à l'occasion mais on
nous demande bien où ça non souillés que
les savoirs ne sont plus la priorité
donc dans les écoles qui fera avant tout
favoriser le l'autonomie de l'élève ce
que vous dit tout à l'heure le laisser
seul face à leurs difficultés
tellement c'est ce qu'on appelle le
laisser en autonomie or quand on débute
on se dit oui bien sûr le il est
important pour les élèves qu'ils se
sentent bien dans la classe surtout moi
particulièrement en maternelle avant
d'apprendre ensuite tous les savoirs
scientifiques
or finalement se trouve un petit peu
dépassé et démuni face finalement ce
devoir et d'éducateurs qu'on nous
demande d'avoir un petit peu du jour au
lendemain
surtout lorsqu'on sort finalement du
monde étudiant là d'un bac +5 qu'on nous
demande de devenir un petit peu d
finalement les éducateurs et donc je me
retrouve à faire
voilà donc à faire la première rentrée
avec une classe de maternelle ou
finalement
j'ai des difficultés à mettre à faire
juste un clin à installer un climat
d'écouté simplement dans une classe plus
de cinq minutes les élèves ne reste pas
en place les élèves coupent la parole ne
s'écoute pas il n'ya plus que vous
disiez ce rapport à l'autorité du maître
en fait moi j'avais pour souvenirs d'en
voilà dans ma classe de maternelle mois
et enfin ton avec comme on ressentait
comme une sorte d'intimidation face à
l'adulte quand on est heureux au prix
voilà sa bd on était sensible à à
l'autorité est donc on ne retrouve plus
ça en fait aujourd'hui dans l'école et
on est interpellé on est étonné et on
doit on doit s'adapter à tout ça et on
redouble d'efforts on s'épuise à essayer
de trouver des solutions pour pour
amener les élèves simplement écouter a
finalement on la voit là un devoir
davantage d'éducation plutôt que de
transmission est en fait à vouloir parce
que dans le fond ce que l'on veut c'est
leur faire apprendre c'est les faire
progresser à les voir réussir de jour en
jour c'est ce qui nous donne goût ce qui
nous donne envie d'exercer ce métier et
finalement à vouloir essayer de se faire
les deux on a l'impression on a ce
sentiment de ne pas y arriver et de
n'arriver ni finalement à éduquer
puisque comme vous disiez il ya des
problématiques sociales à des
problématiques familiales et finalement
d'un moment on réalise qu'elles ne sont
plus notre sort on se sent plus ou moins
démunis parfois face à certaines
difficultés des enfants
donc on a l'impression d' échouer
finalement sur ce plan là est aussi sur
le point de savoir puisque comme vous le
disiez à l'instant ils sont de moins en
moins présents dans l'est dans les
programmes qu'on les enlève même de
notre formation à nous puisque en
institut de formation on insiste plus
sur comment allons nous apprendre de
l'histoire les sciences
comment allons nous apprendre à écrire
non l'est finalement les solutions qu'on
nous donne on nous donne ce sont lisez
les manuels regardé sur internet les
savoir où vous vous débrouillerez plus
ou moins avec ce que vous trouverez par
ci par là nous on vous apprend on a
installé un climat de classe serein à
les rendre en sécurité je dis bien en
sécurité puisque c'est ce sur quoi on
est on est jugé en tant que nouvelle
recrue au palais tous là tout à l'heure
du recrutement des professeurs
nous ne sommes pas juger sur nos
connaissances en mathématiques en
français sur notre manière d'écrire
toute manière nous exprimer mais sur nos
capacités justement à encadrer des
élèves à faire le gendarme dit bien vous
êtes d'aidé
d'armes où vous devez apprendre à régler
les problèmes de discipline allait
rendre tout en les rendant bien sûr
autonome face à leurs difficultés etc
et donc quand on prend ceci en compte
plus les effectifs toujours plus
croissant les élèves qui ont des
troubles plus ou moins neurologique qui
est logique des handicaps qui ne sont
peut-être pas forcément encore décès on
n'a pas encore donc net pour ces enfants
là on se retrouve finalement un peu
démunis et donc un peu perdu entre voilà
ceux de voir un petit peu d'éducateurs
et en même temps cette envie de
transmettre et de transmettre aux élèves
le goût d'apprendre
voilà ce que je peux ressentir moi en
tant que voilà un truc que jeune
enseignante en tant que jeune recrue de
l'enseignement de l'éducation nationale
merci merci beaucoup camille pour ce
témoignage très intéressant c'est vrai
qu'avec monsieur gossio on a beaucoup
parlé du collège et du lycée mais mais
ça nous permet d'aborder ce sujet là
est-ce que vous monsieur broussier vous
avez quelque chose à dire à rebondir sur
sur 7 sur ce premier témoignage et
éventuellement des questions pour
approfondir pour approfondir ce thème de
l'enseignement dès le plus jeune âge et
je pense que ce témoignage est
révélateur de la désillusion de la
désillusion des gens qui ont choisi ce
métier parce qu'il pensait pouvoir
enseigner et puis finalement qui se
retrouvent sur le terrain avec des
contraintes auxquelles ils n'avaient pas
pensé et moi ya quelque chose qui m'a
marqué c'est la formation des
enseignants finalement cette professeure
des écoles mais très bien en avant le
fait qu on ne lui apprend plus à
maîtriser les savoirs disciplinaires
mais on lui apprend à essayer de mettre
en place des séquences pédagogiques clé
en main qui finalement ne maîtrisent pas
les savoirs disciplinaires
ce n'est pas très grave ce qui
évidemment ce qui n'est pas possible on
peut pas enseigner de cette manière
surtout qui lie actuellement de répondre
capes qui fait qu'on est en train de
vider la part disciplinaire le capes et
le concours qui permet de recruter les
enseignants pour l'agrégation est encore
sous garde et heureusement mais le capes
et le concours qui permet de recruter
les enseignants et finalement va se
retrouver avec des professeurs par
exemple d'anglais qui vont être recrutés
alors qu'ils n'ont pas passé des preuves
d'anglais à l'eau
ça pose quand même question moi
j'aimerais aussi demandé si vous voulez
à cette professeure des écoles combien
elle gagne par mois alors je pense que
c'est aussi une question importante
voilà quel est votre salaire
actuellement
alors mon salaire et de 1484 euros par
mois donc je suis ce qu'on appelle en
année de professeurs stagiaires
j'ignore celui que j'aurais l'année
prochaine mais voilà 1484 euros par mois
avec mon c'est un petit peu particulier
mais étant donné qu'on suit une
formation à distance c'est que moi les
voilà je dois prendre en charge donc mes
déplacements j'ai également 100 euros de
plus donc ça fait unique 584 euros
mais la base est 1484 à moins évidemment
ce n'est pas acceptable
comment voulez vous recruter des gens en
masquant après un bac +5 et la réussite
d'un concours on propose mille cinq
cents balles par mois et si ces
professeurs sont mutés en région
parisienne ne peuvent même pas se loger
dans les regarder où on en est
aujourd'hui donc après il faut pas être
étonné qu'on arrive plus à recruter ou
quand on recrute finalement on trouve
parfois des gens qui ne tiennent pas
forcément eu la route et j'ai aussi une
autre question parce que cette
professeur des écoles est dans une
période assez compliquée qui est l'année
de l'année de fonctionnaire stagiaire ou
signalements à la fin de l'année on va
lui dire si elle peut continuer dans
l'éducation nationale ou au contraire si
elle doit refaire une année de stage ou
au contraire être viré de l'éducation
nationale moi j'aimerais bien savoir
comment elle vit cette année et est ce
qu elle ressemble dépression notamment
des pressions idéologiques
alors je ressens la pression idéologique
d'ailleurs on fait remonter
régulièrement mais bon voilà on n'avance
pas énormément de solutions
on ressent cette pression ce qui
concerne comme vous lisiez la mise en
place des séquences dessin en tout ce
jargon de l'éducation nationale qui nous
perd nos progression nos programmations
on nous demande d'avoir une organisation
absolument parfaite on nous demande
vraiment de nous vendre les mots que
j'utilise sont vraiment ceux de maçon à
peine de ma tutrice ceux qui s'occupent
de me2 m'observait de mme inspecté plus
ou moins à des maîtres des comptes
rendus sur moi on nous demande vraiment
de nous vendre tout en parallèle donc
en suivant la formation en étant en
étant présent en rendant des dossiers
etc puisque j'ai la formation de master
- continue donc j'ai aussi un mémoire à
faire renoncer ce n'est pas le cas de
tous les professeurs stagiaires mais
j'essaie de près sur la en plus donc oui
la pression et de logique on la ressent
au niveau de suivi des programmes d'aidé
compétences si bien que on finit par
perdre finalement le goût de la
préparation de la classe où on cherche
des idées et des projets en fait tout ce
qui nous anime en tant que professeur
finalement fini par le perdre parce que
on est obsédé par il faut que je fasse
une séquence une séance en suivant les
bonnes étapes didactique pédagogique en
suivant différentes modalités de travail
vous savez ces travaux par groupes plus
ou moins autonomie tout en ayant comme
en iran en anticipant en même temps tout
ce qui peut se passer dans la classe en
maternelle
la particularité de la maternelle et qui
il veut quand il peut se passer
n'importe quoi pas tous d'une minute à
l'autre finalement on bascule d'une
ambiance de travail à une autre ont tous
le groupe peut être pertubé par le
moindre et les mains et donc on ressent
énormément pression autant du point de
vue de la préparation de suite des
programmes qu en même temps dans la
classe sur le terrain il incite
énormément sur notre capacité à nous
adapter à toutes les situations et en
fait on nous avons donc un an que vous
lisiez et à la fin de cette année on est
même des aides des avis sont émis sur
nous donc positif ou négatif
on passe devant les commissions si
besoin pour justifier notre pratique
voilà et ensuite un nouvel ide ou non
nous dit oui au sablou vous êtes amis
dans l'éducation nationale à plein temps
ou non vous pouvez peut-être faire appel
ou voilà après ça mon problème décision
merci beaucoup pour ce témoignage
camille donc on a presque tout faire on
a fait maternelle collège lycée je pense
que c'est la bonne occasion pour
finalement terminer sur le prix mais
boucler la boucle
je vais appeler marie claire à cette
fois ci qu'il enseignante dans le
primaire marie claire est ce que vous
avez aussi un témoignage à nous apporter
observer sur le terrain alors vous avez
alors abordé le sujet de l'autorité des
fêtes que les propres sont sous payés je
trouve qu'effectivement vous arrivez
raison ce n'est pas une profession qui
visitent la leko aussi dû au fait que la
place de l'école dans la société n'est
plus ce qu'elle était il ya encore au
début de ma carrière donc il ya 25 ans
mais dont j'avais beaucoup de petites
d'élèves qui rêvait de devenir des
crèches des cas les mêmes n'ont pas du
tout aimé mais hélas veulent devenir
reine battait ou gagner le concours de
boys pour devenir chanteur professionnel
chanteuse professionnelle ou youtube
buzz voilà on on est dans ce qui sera
réussi
sans pouvoir montrer le côté difficile
rébarbatif nom de l'apprentissage
et parce qu'il permet d'être célèbre je
suis assez vous avez parlé je reprends
les quotas vous parlez de parents
démissionnaires
je ne dirais pas ça évidemment c'est
toujours difficile quand on parle de
l'éducation d'une manière générale
d'être de vie ne peut pas généraliser
tous les parents ne sont pas
démissionnaires et j'espère vous qui
êtes étudiante que vous n'avez pas de
parents démissionnaires évidemment non
je trouve cependant les voyages si
l'évolution que je constate
au début de ma carrière j'avais je
recevais des parents se fait normalement
en place après la classe dos et c'était
les parents qui me posaient des
questions au sujet des apprentissages
leurs enfants il était question
uniquement de la scolarité
comment sait-il qu'il fasse autant
d'erreurs assez dicter comment s'est il
n'arrive pas à retenir les tables de
multiplication ou bien commencé d'une
france et son savoir c'était des
échanges qui portait sur le scolaire et
maintenant on a de plus en plus des
échanges qui porte sur l'éducatif
on a des parents mais je suis pas psy de
parents qui me disait au début de ma
carrière
si vous lui donnez une punition
n'hésitez pas si la mérite
allgoob la sphère la maison à il y a
quinze ans oui ils commencent que vous
me donner des punitions
certainement que vous maîtrisiez à tort
enfin ce que vous êtes des vraiment
qu'ils vont certainement pas voulu
voilà donc l'enfant n'était plus aux
coupables a maintenant des parents qui
viennent me racontiez qui n'arrivent
plus à coucher des enfants que leur en
france et des crises fait des comédies
et qui appelle au secours
voilà le sud le je suis très étonné ce
n'est pas 100% des entretiens que j'ai
avec les parents bien entendu il reste
des parents qui se passe bien leurs
enfants et qui ont des principes
éducatifs
évidemment et heureusement mais marie
claire excusez-moi de vous couper merci
marie claire pour pour ce témoignage
éclairant également peut-être que
monsieur bossuet a également une
interaction affaire avec vous peut-être
des questions d des éléments de réponse
à apporter
oui tout d'abord oui quand je dis que
les parents sont démissionnaires
évidemment c'est certains parents alors
c'est vrai que sur certains territoires
c'est peut-être plus important que dans
d'autres
alors après si vous voulez ce qui me
marque dans votre témoignage c'est ce
changement de paradigme notamment la
manière dont les parents vont à l'école
et c'est vrai que ça a beaucoup évolué
et aujourd'hui si vous voulez j'ai
l'impression que l'école c'est devenu
vraiment un service public type la caf
c'est à dire que les délais aux parents
attendent attendre vont à l'école si
vous voulez comme ils vont aller
chercher leurs allocations sociales
c'est-à-dire qu'ils attendent des
enseignants qui ne se justifient
pourquoi vous avez fait telle ou telle
chose ils disent mais vous n'avez pas le
droit de faire si vous n'avez pas le
droit de faire ça si vous faites ça mal
on va on va en parler au directeur
d'école où on va pas en parler au
proviseur ou principal
ils sont tous temps là dedans dont la
contestation et ne se rendent pas compte
qu'ils saccagent l'aspect éducatif parce
qu'à partir du moment où les enfants
voile distorsion entre ce que disent les
enseignants et ce que disent les parents
forcés prend les gamins s'engouffre dans
la brèche et une enseignements après est
très compliqué et l'éducation et saccagé
et surtout c'est que ses parents sont
aussi beaucoup dans la négociation c'est
qu'ils vont nous voir vous avez mis 4
sur 20 est ce que c'est possible
finalement d'augmenter un petit peu la
note ou est ce que c'est possible de
donner un devoir de rattrapage vous avez
donné une punition est ce que c'est
possible de réduire la taille de la
punition
enfin voilà c'est ça qui est dramatique
c'est qu'intel affaissement de la plage
du professeur dans la société ou de la
place de l'école dont la société que
finalement on est vu comme d'aider des
gens complètement déprécier sur
lesquelles certains parents peuvent
s'essuyer comme s'essuie ray sur un
paillasson
et c'est dévastateur et c'est dramatique
et moi c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup marqué
dans ce témoignage qui est très
intéressant parce que vu que cette
professeure et à la fin de sa carrière
on voit très bien
l'évolution entre la conception des cols
qui était au début de la carrière et
puis finalement ce qui est devenue
l'école de la république dont la société
de manière plus générale on se dirait
maintenant vous avez les des collégiens
dont que les enfants qui est un des
élèves qui ont cette man de plus que mes
élèves ont quoi arriver en maternelle
les parents maternels qui au contraire
appelle au secours des parents je vous
assure des parents et les gens de père
de famille en larmes ni revenir à
l'enseignement maternel
quels conseils pouvez-vous donner on
n'arrive plus à avoir de l'autorité sur
notre enfant de trois ans c'était mon
cas particulièrement c'est ce qui m'a
principalement marqué lors de ma rentrée
c'est que j'ai dû donner je ne me
sentais presque voilà demander un
conseil éducatif et vous pensez bien que
ah voilà quand on n'a même pas 25 ans de
donner des conseils à des parents se
posent la question de la légitimité de
mais qu'est ce que je peux leur dire en
fait à ses parents et ses terribles
c'est vraiment terrible voilà on en est
là on évolue vers cela et je vous
connais vous dire que je vais partir le
mois prochain pour une année de
formation en université pour faire 2
pour m'informer en accompagnement à la
parentalité
parce que je sens que maintenant c'est
ce dont j'ai besoin pour enseigner c'est
sûr et c'est je suis d'accord et c'est
vrai que sur le terrain ce qui souffre
le plus de cela ce sont surtout ces
familles monoparentales vers ces mamans
qui sont seuls pour élever leurs enfants
qui se lève à 5 heures du matin pour
aller travailler qui rentrent le soir il
est très très tard et finalement qui
n'ont plus le temps de s'occuper de
leurs enfants et qui sont finalement
complètement dépassées et c'est vrai
qu'on le voit sur le terrain et c'est
dramatique et l'école est là pour
essuyer toutes ses carences éducatives
et finalement toute la misère
2 la société où tous les problèmes de la
société repose sur ou petit enseignants
sur le que forcément on n'a pas
forcément les réponses puisque on n'a
pas été formés pour ça et que tout
simplement ce n'est pas non plus
toujours mon rôle moi j'enseigne si vous
voulez sur des territoires qui sont
considérées comme perdues cheveux pâles
terre ou dans ce territoire là je
rencontre des gamins ce formidable qui
veulent réussir etc mais ils ont souvent
besoin d'un papa qui est absent ils ont
souvent besoin d'un grand frère qui est
absente de conseil dans leur vie de tous
les jours ils ne trouvent pas ils ne
trouvent pas au sein du cercle familial
donc c'est vrai qu'ils vont le chercher
chez nous sauf que moi mon rôle c'est
pas d'être un second papa mon rôle n'est
pas d'être un grand frère mon rôle c'est
de transmettre des connaissances mais je
le fais parce que j'aime beaucoup mes
élèves et j'essaye de les aider et de
les accompagner du mieux possible mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya un peu un dévoiement
de notre rôle premier
et c'est ce qui explique la désillusion
de la jeune enseignante
on a entendu tout à fait et en plus dans
mon précédent donc au fur et à mesure en
formation que un élève qui n'est pas
bien dans son sacré milliards qui
connaît des voiles à des problèmes des
problématiques se servent personnel il
ne sera pas disponible pour les
apprentissages et donc nous nous devons
en prendre compte aussi pour mieux
comprendre l'enfant pour faire preuve de
bienveillance pour l'accompagner et c
est donc finalement on doit prendre
toutes ces problématiques là sur nos
j'avais vraiment sous-estimé
personnellement l'impact familial dans
l'apprentissage des enfants même sur sur
moi en fait c'est à dire que ce sont des
problématiques qui nous touche forcément
parce que nous nous sommes humains et au
titre puisque voilà je débuts dans la
profession et donc on est touché par
toutes ces problématiques les a des
enfants on en a entre 20 et 1 25 et 30
et donc vous imaginez bien qu'ensuite
pour faire élire le savoir dans toutes
ces problématiques là on se sent bloqués
et démunis est vraiment parfois vraiment
impuissant
merci merci beaucoup pour pour ces
témoignages merci à marie claire merci à
camille et merci à vous monsieur bossuet
pour pour cette entrevue qui fut très
intéressante
merci à vous malheureusement les
constats sont sont très préoccupants
très inquiétant sur l'état de notre
école républicaine sur l'état de notre
modèle d'éducation et j'espère que des
solutions pourront être retrouvées à
terme j'espère que
améliorations pourront être fait parce
que les on a des témoignages de
d'enseignants qui sont qui sont vraiment
inquiétant en tout cas nous nous vous
remercions tous au nom de scopeo pour
cette ce débat qui fut très intéressant
qui permet justement d'animer le débat
qui permet de favoriser l'émulation
intellectuelle nous vous remercions tous
tous et roy et maxime également vous
vous remerciera je vous remercie
énormément c'est une très belle façon de
conclure cette série d'articles sur
l'éducation j'en lis tous nos auditeurs
et auditrices qui n'auraient pas eu
l'occasion de les lire à aller voir sur
scopeo point org et je n'aurais pas pu
rêver d'une meilleure façon d'avoir
autant de pratiques avec la théorie pour
pouvoir conclure cette série donc merci
du merci aussi à vous du sacrifice que
vous faites tous les jours d'enseignés
de malgré malgré tous les problèmes
qu'on a évoqué les salaires malgré le
manque de respect malgré le manque de
temps c'est un très très beau métier que
vous faites
il pense que tous les gens qui nous ont
écoutés on sera encore un peu plus
confiant grâce à vous aujourd'hui j'ai
bien insisté pour dire que c'est un très
beau métier
la pandémie nous a permis a permis à
beaucoup de parents de se rendre compte
de l'importance de notre rôle lorsqu'ils
se sont retrouvés eux mêmes à devoir
faire l'école à la maison
et oui oui c'est vrai que cette pandémie
nous fait réaliser de nombreuses choses
merci à vous je vous souhaite à tous une
bonne journée et nous nous retrouvons
très vite sur ce coupé au point org
merci à vous